hey guys now I've heard a lot of people
say Daniel I can't eat a healthy food
because it's just so expensive well is
it well yeah some healthy food can be
expensive that's true but if you believe
all healthy food are expensive you got a
lot to learn because it is not so in
this video I'm gonna give you five tips
to eat a healthy food on a budget let's
get to it mistakes mistakes make you
strong just very quick if it's your
first time here on my channel I'm Daniel
and welcome to DLM model
lifestyle consider subscribing and also
clicking that notification bell so you
won't miss any of the next videos now
let's start with the first step buy in
bulk because it's cheaper so most of the
expensive stuff that you want to buy you
can buy it in bulk because it works out
cheaper especially when it's on sale
then you also save time and you also
save money on fuel because if you buy in
bulk you don't need to go to the store
so often as you usually do buy whole
food instead of processed food a lot of
people who say healthy food is expensive
they don't realize just how expensive
some of the processed foods really are
and it's unhealthy like chicken nuggets
for example they're not cheap or at
least not in South Africa if you compare
them to normal chicken but stay away
from processed foods choose the right
food that are healthy and cheap and
throw away all the junk for example if
you have breakfast
choose oatmeal which is super cheap in
most countries and you can achieve
fruits with the oats like bananas and it
tastes great but unfortunately most
people choose these unhealthy cereals
and they're not really cheap and your
kids get used to them and instead of
buying sodas like Coke get coffee tea or
fruit juice and then bread is usually
cheap but instead of going for that
unhealthy white bread choose whole grain
or
wheat-bread and then most people who go
grocery shopping you forget how many
sweets and crackers and junk you put in
to your trolley right and then those
bills it's expensive so stop buying junk
food like crackers cookies sodas and pre
packed food it's expensive and offers
almost no nutritional value and then buy
more vegetables there's a lot of cheap
vegetables that you can get like
broccoli onions spinach sweet potatoes
and normal potatoes tomatoes carrots
green cabbage and butternut squash and
then when you look at grains and legumes
brown rice is affordable I already
talked about oatmeal and then there's
quinoa which is so healthy although this
can be expensive in some countries like
South Africa when you look at fish and
meat canned tuna is usually cheaper than
normal fresh fish and eggs
I mean eggs so healthy and they are so
cheap and then if you like me to get
chicken because chicken is cheap in most
countries and if you buy it in bulk he's
saved even more all right
I've been going on a little bit too much
so let's move on to the next step plan
your meals and cook at home you gotta
plan ahead for the week that's coming so
make a grocery list and stick to the
grocery list never go buy groceries when
you're hungry it's not gonna work
because then you just want to buy
everything so stick to the list and then
only buy the food that you're sure
you'll use so you won't waste any food
and in so doing waste your money and
then cooking at home is a lot cheaper
than eating out if you say no it's
expensive to eat at home then you should
check your bills at the end of the month
to see how much you're actually really
paying for eating out so instead of
eating out a lot use that same money and
buy a healthy food that you can eat at
home and then a good tip is to use the
weekend to plan and cook your food ahead
for the week that is coming
and then another good tip is to buy
generic
products what is this well it's
basically those products that doesn't
have a brand name or trademark now these
products are usually cheaper and all
food manufacturers have to follow the
same standards to provide safe food but
generic products are usually the same
quality as branded food products now
listen you don't need to take out your
savings just to eat a healthy but you
can make better choices so stop dieting
with one month and then you go on an
eating spree and then you dye it again
stop the diets and just live a healthy
lifestyle remember eating junk food
actually cost you twice as much
especially if you look in the long run
when you look at your health
bad food comes with bad health and bad
health comes with medical bills and
drugs and even low energy depression and
so forth and remember this you can't put
a price on good health now if you want
to learn more about eating healthy and
check out my older video over here and
I'll see you there cheers guys